shawn mendes uses his um performance at
the iheart radio wango tango festival to
raise awareness about any gun violence
in the united states
yeah sean took the stage in an orange
t-shirt to support the cause and later
encouraged his followers on instagram to
tell your senators to take action on gun
safety now by texting bold to 64433
here's a look at his performance
[Music]
i don't wanna know what it's like
[Music]
he is incredible i know he's just not
just a great musician but you know he's
using his platform 68.7 million
followers on instagram right now i just
had to see what the latest count was uh
you know talking about such important
issues i think this is great he's he's a
wonderful role model right now he's also
really honest about struggles with
mental health like he just really owns
everything that's going on he tries to
you know normalize a lot of things that
people don't want to talk about
he's very thoughtful i think that every
move that he makes
um i think that sometimes cripples him
too he's talked about that but he's
incredibly thoughtful with what he puts
out into the world and he always tries
to put good things out there and so we
love him for that we love him he's
canadian he's also super tall not that
that's important great when it comes to
this great discussion you see that
jawline when he was with the guitar i
know all the guys were like look at that
jawline because he's yeah he's just
amazing i uh i actually haven't
interviewed him but when he walked by me
at the juno's red carpet little little
source still that he uh didn't do press
that night but that's okay i totally
appreciate it um he's so tall
i didn't realize how tall he was yeah
and most celebrities those people
probably know this are usually really
short yeah and very tiny but he's like a
very tall just didn't expect it tall man
yeah we love him we do